[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATHAN RUNKLE: So today, I
want to talk a little bit
about my story, founding
Mercy for Animals, the work
that we do to give
farmed animals a voice
on an international level,
why animals even matter,
and what the future of our
food system can look like.
So I guess you could
say it makes sense
that I would start an
international animal rights
organization given the
fact that I was actually
delivered by a veterinarian.
My dad, Mark, who you see
illegally driving around
with me in this photograph,
was a veterinarian,
graduated from OSU.
And I was born on
the couch at home
in a village of less than
2,000 people in rural Ohio.
So I was slated to be a
fifth generation farmer,
but my love for animals
and fascination for animals
would lead me on a
very different path.
Now, they say that big lessons
can come in small packages,
and that was definitely
the case for me.
And that little package
was a rat named Cesar.
When I was six years old, I
went across the cornfields
from our house to a couple
whose name was Gene and Sylvia,
and they actually raised animals
for research in laboratories.
They raised rabbits, mice,
rats, and guinea pigs,
and they rented the
property from my parents.
And one afternoon
when I went over there
with my mom to collect
that month's rent check,
Sylvia asked if I wanted to
see the animals because she
knew of my deep love for them.
And I said, yes, of course.
She took me inside of the sheds.
And now I really look back in
horror at what I saw there.
These animals crammed in
tiny cages, dead animals
in the corners, the
smell of ammonia.
She reached into
one of the cages
and pulled this white
rat out by his tail
and lowered him into my
hands, and I begged her
to allow me to take him home.
And she said yes.
My mother said yes.
And I named this
little guy Cesar.
And he became my best friend
for about 2 and 1/2 years.
He would sit on my shoulder
as I went around the house.
He knew his name.
He would come running
when I called him.
And I realized just how
intelligent and social
these animals are.
How they have their own
unique personalities.
But Cesar also taught
me about the prejudices
that humans bring to the
table with certain animals.
And he started to peel back
the layers of my own view,
as a young child,
about what separates
animals that we consider
to be pests from those
that we consider to
be pets, and those
that we consider friends and
those that we consider food.
I would take friends and
friends' parents to see Cesar,
and so many of them would shriek
in horror and disgust, saying,
ew, a rat.
Look at his tail.
They didn't know him as
an individual as I did.
They were judging Cesar for
what he was, not who he was.
I started to realize
from Cesar that when
it comes to having
personalities,
and minds, and interests,
and a spark for life,
that all animals
are really equal,
and the difference is only
our perception of them.
About six years later, another
big, life changing lesson
came in also a small package,
and that was a baby piglet.
My local high school in
this farming community
had an agriculture class.
And the teacher of that class,
Mr. Jenkins, was a pig farmer.
And it came time
in the curriculum
where they were going to
do a dissection project,
and Mr. Jenkins decided
that he would kill some baby
piglets on his farm.
He raised over 10,000
pigs, a large operation.
He arrived one May
morning in 1999
with this bucket of
piglets to the classroom,
and when he got there, one of
the piglets was still alive.
A student in the class, who did
part-time work on Mr. Jenkins'
farm, walked over to the
bucket, picked up this piglet
by her hind legs, and slammed
her head first into the ground.
Now, this piglet, which
you see right here
in these photographs,
didn't die.
She was determined to survive.
Her skull was fractured.
She was bleeding
out of her mouth.
She was vocalizing in distress.
A few students, who were
just absolutely appalled
by what they had
witnessed, grabbed
this now dying animal,
left the classroom,
went down the hallway to
Molly Fearing's classroom--
another teacher
in the school who
was known as being
the vegetarian who
cared about animals.
She left the school, went
to a local veterinarian,
and had this poor
piglet euthanized.
There was nothing they
could do to help her.
Molly's next stop was the
local Sheriff's department
where she filed an
animal cruelty complaint,
asking that charges be
brought, and they were.
The very first
day of that trial,
however, the cruelty
charges were dismissed.
And that's because in
Ohio, like most states,
if something is considered
standard agricultural practice,
it's exempt from
cruelty prosecution.
And the practice of slamming
baby piglets head first
into the ground is considered
standard agricultural practice,
known as thumping in
the pork industry.
It is considered a
cheap and effective way
of killing animals.
Now this case, to
me as a 15-year-old,
illustrated that
there needed to be
an organization in my
local farming community
that would advocate on
behalf of these animals.
It was clear to me, had
this been a puppy or kitten,
the outcome would have
been completely different.
The cruelty charges
would have stuck,
and the teacher would
have been referred
for psychiatric
evaluation, perhaps banned
from ever having animals again.
But because it was a pig, the
outcome was very different.
So I started Mercy for Animals.
We had no money, no resources.
I had no idea what
I was doing, but I
had a passion to right
a wrong and give a voice
to these animals who suffer.
Today, Mercy for Animals works
in four main program areas.
The first, undercover
investigation-- sending people
into factory farms
and slaughterhouses,
wired with pinhole-sized
hidden cameras,
to document what takes
place behind the closed
doors of industrial
factory farms,
hatcheries, livestock auctions,
when the industry doesn't
think that it is being watched.
And I'll talk more
about that later.
We also work through legal
advocacy, changing laws,
pushing on a federal level,
but also on a state level
to outlaw the worst
factory farm practices.
Through corporate outreach,
pushing the largest
corporations in this country--
everyone from Wal-Mart
to McDonald's-- to also abandon
the cruelest factory farm
practices.
And finally, through consumer
education and awareness
campaigns--
informing people on
the fact that animals
are individuals with unique
minds and personalities.
Their lives matter,
the treatment of them
matters, and that our
food choices also matter.
And moving towards a vegan
diet, moving away from animals
and towards plants.
This incident taught
me at a young age
that we all have power.
Just the fact that
we were born human
puts us in a place of power.
To be in a time
and a country where
we are able to speak
freely also gives us power.
And Mercy for
Animals has been one
of the most empowering
experiences of my life,
being able to advocate on
those who have no voice.
Dr. King once said
that our lives
begin to end the day that we
become silent about things
that matter.
So I want to talk
about people who
are using their place of power
to help animals and speak out
about things that matter.
One such individual
is Dr. Jane Goodall.
Now she says, we
have to understand
that we are not the only
beings on this planet
with personalities and minds.
Now, most of us are at least
somewhat familiar with the work
of Dr. Goodall, who
spent over 40 years
living with and observing
chimpanzees in Africa.
Now, she started to do
this work at a time when
even the veterinary community
was not united in the belief
and understanding that all
animals felt physical pain, let
alone that they had rich
intellectual and emotional
lives.
It was through
Dr. Goodall's work
that we started to understand
that many of the false barriers
and walls that we
put up between us
and other animals were,
in fact, non-existent.
She witnessed and
documented animals
having culture, having
language, using tools, grieving
for the loss of loved ones.
This is an image that I think
really shows friendship,
and loyalty, and love.
These are two dogs in China.
Now, they were street dogs.
They never had a
human companion.
They were never given
names by people.
But to each other,
they meant everything.
One afternoon,
the female was hit
and she was killed by a car.
Her loyal companion stayed
by her side for hours on end,
licking her face, nudging her,
dodging traffic to comfort her.
This is, of course, just
one example of that bond.
And we live in a
country where half of us
share our homes
with dogs and cats.
And of those
animals, half of them
will receive gifts
this holiday season.
We spend billions of
dollars on their care
and toys and medical procedures,
yet we live in a country
where billions, literally
billions of animals
suffer and die the
worst fate imaginable.
And those, of course,
are farmed animals.
And part of what
Mercy for Animals does
is help to bridge the
gap in our empathy
and our understanding
of animals,
to widen our circle
of compassion
to include those that,
for all too long,
have simply been labeled food.
This is another image that
tells a story of love.
This image is from India.
This mother cow's baby was
hit and killed by a bus.
For two years, she
stayed in the same area.
And every time that the bus
that hit and killed her baby
came by, she would slowly
walk along it in front of it
as if trying to prevent the bus
from killing any other animals.
Now, the bus driver became
so frustrated by this
that he actually
painted the bus trying
to disguise it and
fool this mother cow,
but she wasn't fooled.
She remembered the face
of the man who drove
the bus that killed her baby.
So this, of course, shows
not only emotional empathy,
but also a prolonged
memory as well.
Now, of course animals
tell us so much
if we will just bother to
listen and watch and observe.
And often times, science
is slow to catch up
with what that would tell us,
but finally, that is happening.
Just a few years ago, hundreds
of the leading scientists
signed the Cambridge
Declaration of Consciousness.
And what this says is
that all animals are just
as conscious and
aware as humans.
And we're not just
talking about mammals.
We're talking about birds,
fish, and even octopus.
This is a headline
just from the last week
that appeared in
"The New York Times."
Fish depression is not a
joke, talking about depression
in fish in captivity, where
they are kept in enclosures
with no stimulation.
So much so that fish are being
used to study antidepressants.
This article from
"Smithsonian"--
Fido's making that
puppy face on purpose.
He's trying to
tell you something.
And of course, this
all makes sense.
When we think about our
singular place of life forming,
of evolution beginning,
it makes sense
that other animals
would remember
faces of friends and foes.
It helps with their survival.
Bonding and empathy also
helps with their survival.
Not to mention, of course,
physical pain being
necessary for their survival.
But we have grown
so disconnected.
We start to view ourselves as
different from other animals--
separate from.
But only 70,000 years ago,
there are at least six species
of humans on this Earth--
Neanderthals, Homo erectus,
[INAUDIBLE],, and others.
But about 10,000
years ago, things
started to change as we
domesticated plants and animals
in the Neolithic period,
and we started agriculture.
We became stationary rather
than hunter or gatherers.
And with that, we built walls--
literal walls-- between
us and the natural world
and our animal cousins.
And that agriculture that
once sustained us and allowed
us to start civilization as
we know it in human history,
as we know it, has
gone completely awry,
leading to factory
farms, other animals not
being viewed as
sentient creatures,
but as production units,
as machines, as resources.
And I believe that we must shift
and have an ethical evolution
that encompasses animals.
And I think that this
quote from "The Economist"
sums up that march forward well.
It says, "Historically,
man has expanded
the reach of his ethical
calculations, as ignorance
and wants have receded, first
beyond family and tribe,
later beyond religion,
race, and nation.
Bringing other
species more fully
into the range of
these decisions one day
may seem no more than
civilized behavior requires."
And we are starting to see
this ethical march forward
in our treatment of animals, in
our understanding of animals.
After over 130 years of
confining elephants, of ripping
them from their families,
capturing them in the wild,
of beating tigers, Ringling
Brothers and Barnum and Bailey
Circus, citing
declining attendance
and new legal restrictions
against their acts,
has permanently shut down.
And we are starting to
see an increased awareness
of the problems of keeping orcas
and dolphins in confinement
at places like SeaWorld.
And I predict in
the next few years,
we will see similar
announcements
from SeaWorld and similar
aquatic parks that
will also retire these animals
to oceanside sanctuaries.
This just from the
last few weeks--
California puppy mill ban
will require pet stores
to sell rescue animals.
California becoming
the first state
in the nation to
ban the sale of dogs
from puppy mills in pet stores,
taking effect in January 2019.
So there is a march forward
in our treatment of animals.
But when we talk
about animals, we're
really talking about
farmed animals,
though they are the
most absent, the most
invisible from our scenario.
We don't go home to
a pig-- most of us.
We don't share our homes
with them, but most of us
don't know them as individuals.
But as this chart shows,
they really are the 99%.
The yellow, showing the
number of farmed animals
used in this country.
The blue, animals and labs.
Gray, shelters.
And in black, clothing.
Nearly 9 billion in
the US every year.
That's about 300 every second.
We're looking at
hundreds of billions
on an international level when
you include aquatic life, which
of course, we should.
And this is what
most people really
know about factory farming--
very little.
And that is by design.
Obviously, there
is so much money
pumped into portraying this
false image that happy meat
comes from happy animals.
We are told, from children, that
hamburgers grow in hamburger
patches at McDonald's.
And there is a concerted
effort by the meat industry
to keep people in
the dark-- in fact,
criminalize even taking
photographs inside
of factory farms
and slaughterhouses,
further pulling
the curtain closed.
But at Mercy for
Animals, we believe
that people have a right to know
where their food comes from.
That animals have a right
to have their stories told.
And that's why we carry out
undercover investigations.
And I talk about this
at length in my book,
but I want to tell you
just a little bit about who
these incredible
individuals are.
On the left here is Pete.
Pete is the most prolific
undercover investigator
that the American animal
rights movement has ever seen.
He has been to over
400 puppy mills.
He has been inside of
dozens of factory farms
and slaughterhouses, and
now does investigations
on an international level.
Liz, who you see
here in the middle,
used to work at an
animal sanctuary,
but she knew that if she left
behind her friends and family
and did undercover
investigation,
she would be able to
help even more animals.
And so she did that.
In fact, her work
at Butterball Turkey
led to the first ever felony
conviction for cruelty
to factory farm birds.
And on the right is Cody, who
is a former investigator who
has worked at the largest
dairy farm in New York,
leading to criminal
animal cruelty convictions
and international policy
change, and at a pig factory
farm in Pennsylvania.
And I want to tell you a
story from his work there.
On his first day at this
breeding facility, where
pigs are kept locked
in tiny crates
where they can't turn around,
Cody opened the shed door
and stepped inside.
And he saw mother
pigs with their babies
in farrowing crates.
But he noticed that one
of the cage doors was open
and the mother was in the
hallway with her baby piglets
behind her.
And as he investigated
more, he realized
that, in fact, two
other sows were also
free from their cage and their
piglets following behind.
Cody asked other workers
what had happened.
They did some
investigating, and they
determined that the one
mother sow had figured out
how to use her tongue to
unlatch a pin in the cage door
and liberate herself, and then
freed her piglets behind her.
But she didn't stop there.
She opened the cage doors
of other suffering pigs
around her.
Now, they say that
the definition of love
is having a benevolent
and unselfish concern
for the good of another.
If this isn't an act of
love, I don't know what is.
It certainly is an act
of bravery and courage.
Now, how was she
repaid for this?
She was shot in the head
with a captive bolt gun.
The farm says that once pigs
learn how to free themselves,
they will continue to do
it time and time again.
So that's just one story of
the bravery and courage that's
happening right now
inside of factory farms.
We talked about the physical
pain that animals endure--
and we should-- but there's
also emotional distress
that these animals are
subjected to as well.
At Mercy for Animals, we
focus on doing the most good
that we can.
We realize that we have limited
time, resources, and energy.
So we want to help as
much as we possibly
can, save as many lives,
reduce as much suffering.
So in our campaigns
and in our work,
we look at the number of
animals affected, the duration
of suffering, the
degree of suffering,
and where there are
viable alternatives.
And while we push forward
for a vegan world--
and I'll talk more about that--
we also believe that it's
our ethical obligation
to prevent as much
suffering as we can
for the animals
unfortunate enough to be
born now and in the future.
So part of that
includes changing laws
and pushing for policy
changes, as I mentioned before.
And we look at the
internationally accepted
five freedoms as a
base for that work,
and that's freedom
from hunger and thirst,
freedom from discomfort, freedom
from pain, injury, and disease,
freedom from fear and
distress, and freedom
to express normal behavior.
Simple terms, but vast impact.
That means addressing
the intensive confinement
of animals, like those mother
pigs that I just told you
about, and ending
gestation crates,
ending the confinement of egg
laying hens in battery cages--
file cabinet-sized cages,
where five to seven birds are
kept for their entire lives,
unable to spread their wings,
walk, perch, roost,
[INAUDIBLE],, bathe,
or engage in the most
basic natural behaviors.
It means ending the confinement
of baby calves inside
of veal crates.
And we're having success.
We have pushed many of
the largest players--
everyone from Wal-Mart to
McDonald's-- to address these
abuses.
Now, this doesn't mean that
these animals live happy lives.
And in fact, many
of these commitments
have phase-in periods
of 10 years or more,
but it is moving
the ball forward,
showing that these
animals' lives matter,
and that the treatment of them
during those lives matter.
Our main focus right now
is on birds used for meat.
Broiler chickens-- literally
named after the cooking method.
These are birds that
have been bred to be
almost Frankenstein animals.
Bred to grow so
large and so fast
that they're killed when
they're 45 days old--
babies.
And they suffer under the
weight of their own bodies.
There's not a single federal
law that provides protection
to animals during their
lives on factory farms,
and the only
federal laws that do
exist are related to the
final moments of the animals
lives-- transport and slaughter.
And of that, they exempt
birds, which make up
the 95% of farmed animals.
So the way in which chickens are
killed in this country, that's
considered standard and
legal, would be illegal
if it was a dog or a
cat, and a cow or a pig.
So we're working to
change that as well.
These birds are dumped out of
crates, snapped into shackles.
They have their throats slit
while they're fully conscious
often times, and many of them
go into scalding tanks of water
while they're still alive.
The USDA says at least
a million birds a year,
but we know that the number
is, in fact, much higher.
So we're working to reduce
the suffering of these birds
through pressuring
companies to change
the genetics of these birds,
give them natural light,
enrichments that
they have something
to do during their
miserable existence,
reduce stocking density, and
change slaughter practices.
And in just the last
year, we've been
able to pressure over
100 of the largest food
companies in the world
to make these changes,
affecting over 1 billion birds.
But we're also addressing
this on the political front.
Now, there is no clear
roadmap right now
for federal legislation
that would protect animals.
So we have to look
at the state level.
Half of the states don't
even have ballot initiative
processes, but California does.
And we are part of a coalition
that is launching right now.
An initiative that would end
the cage confinement of birds,
cows, and pigs in
California, but also
the sale of meat and
eggs from birds that
are kept in these enclosures.
So if you're
interested, please go
to preventcrueltyca.com to get
involved in that initiative.
These efforts are
having a real impact,
as I said-- impacting over
1 billion animals year-wide.
$1 to MFA helps 111 animals--
reduce the suffering of these
animals through policy changes,
and spares one animal from ever
being born into factory farms.
This is our view of
effective altruism.
How can we stretch the dollar
to impact the most animals.
Though again, we won't
meet these animals,
but prevention goes so
far in helping them.
We also believe that
where an animal is born,
or where an animal
hatches, shouldn't dictate
whether they live
lives of suffering
or whether they have respect.
We believe that a pig in
China and a pig in the US
deserve the same sort
of consideration.
That a chicken in Canada
or a chicken in Mexico
deserve the same consideration.
And while we make progress
here in the United States,
the truth is, is that only
about 2% of farmed animals
are in the US.
The other 98% are
on a global level--
about half of this in China.
And this includes
fish that are farmed.
And unfortunately, we are seeing
an increase in meat consumption
and production on
a global scale.
In fact, it is estimated that
by 2050, global meat production
will double.
So we need to come up
with innovative ways
to address this, which I'll
talk about a bit later.
One way in which
we're doing this
is by launching offices and
campaigns around the globe.
We now have a presence in six
countries together representing
over half of the global
human population.
These are slides
of investigations
that we carried out in Mexico
at over a dozen government owned
slaughterhouses.
And we documented pigs
having their hearts cut
open while still alive,
being electrically shocked,
hammers being used to kill
adult cows and steers.
Now, we used this
investigation to push
for federal legislation.
And I'm excited to say that it
is moving through the Mexico
legislature as we speak.
In just the last week, it passed
the equivalent of the House
in Mexico, and it is now
going before the Senate.
And we are optimistic
that it will pass
and be signed by the president.
And what this piece
of legislation does
is make it a crime to slit the
throat of animals while still
conscious in slaughterhouses.
Currently, it is not
illegal to do so in Mexico.
But we're also addressing
this at the core,
which is consumer demand for
meat, dairy, and egg products.
Now, we have a lot of
consumer education campaigns
that go directly to
consumers, but we also
are doing institutional
meat reduction work.
And a lot of this
is in Latin America,
where we work with
schools to carry
a vegan only meal that
they carry one day a week--
completely vegan.
And just since launching this
program a few months ago,
we've had over a dozen
successes leading
to a total of 25
million vegan meals
a year being served
through these schools.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Planet Earth, our
one precious home.
Shared with our
fellow earthlings.
Connected and alike through
this shared experience
called life through love,
companionship, joy, family,
and a desire to be free,
but we've lost our way
and betrayed the animals.
We have abused our power.
We have dominated and hurt
our fellow earthlings.
We have locked them in cages
and condemned them to death.
Hearts broken.
Families separated.
Unseen, unheard.
We must turn the tide toward
kindness and compassion.
It is up to us to
expose the truth,
confront cruelty, give a
voice to the voiceless,
and change the world
for them, for all of us.
Together, we can inspire
compassion, stop the violence,
and bring about a
revolution of love.
Together, we can create
a world without cages,
a world without factory farming
or slaughterhouses, a world
without cruelty, a world where
our fellow earthlings are free
again.
To build this compassionate
future, we must act today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
NATHAN RUNKLE: So
how do we build
this compassionate future?
To do that, I want to start
by talking about Henry Ford.
If we look about 100
years ago, the streets
were crowded with horses,
overworked horses that
were pulling carriages
in the blistering heat
and the freezing temperature.
And there were people advocating
on behalf of these horses
and the better
treatment of them.
But what truly changed the game
was something better, faster,
more efficient.
And that was, of
course, the Model T.
History is crowded
with examples of this.
We can look at what helped
drive down the whaling industry.
And yes, it was
international outcry,
but it was also kerosene
and other forms of oil.
If we look at what's happening
right here in Silicon
Valley, how
innovation is changing
the way in which people
travel, where they stay,
how they gather
information, we can
see that simple ideas
can change the world.
And I believe that
animal agriculture
is ripe for this
type of disruption.
Not only is it inhumane, but
it is completely inefficient.
We think about the amount
of grain and energy
that has to be used to produce
that grain to funnel it
through animals to get
a small amount of meat,
it doesn't make sense.
It's not sustainable.
As we race towards a global
population of 9.7 billion
by 2050, we simply can't
grow and feed enough animals
to feed the growing population.
Now, Richard Branson
recently said,
"I believe that
in 30 years or so,
we will no longer need
to kill any animals,
and that all meat will either
be clean or plant-based,
taste the same, and also be
much healthier for everyone."
And Mr. Branson
is a new investor
in Memphis Meats, a company that
was founded by Uma Valeti, who
is a cardiologist.
He was saving
lives in hospitals,
and he realized that in
the medical profession,
they were growing
tissues for quite
some time for medical purposes.
And he thought, can't we use
this same technology to raise
meat-- meat without the murder--
something that Google
has been at the forefront
of, with Sergey Brin,
of course, funding
the first lab-grown burger
from Mark Post just a number
of years ago.
Now, Uma started
Memphis Meats, and it's
called Memphis Meats because
one of his co-founders
is from Memphis and actually
owns and runs barbecue meat
restaurants there and would
like to have clean meat
to be able to serve in
his restaurants one day.
Now Uma and his
team have created
the world's first clean
meatball, but also
chicken and duck products just
in the last few years.
And it is called clean meat
as a nod to clean energy.
It takes about 50% less
energy to produce clean meat,
and produces about 90% less
greenhouse gas emissions,
requires 90% less land
and water as well.
But it's also called clean meat
because it is literally cleaner
to produce in bioreactors,
much the same way
that beer is produced.
So you're not going to find
the same levels of bacteria
contamination--
E. Coli, salmonella,
campylobacter, et cetera.
This chart shows Memphis
Meats' antibiotic and bacteria
levels compared to conventional
and organic levels.
It's pretty clear.
"The Guardian's"
headline sums it up.
They said, "Lab-grown food--
the goal is to remove the animal
from meat production."
And Uma considers this
the second domestication.
The first domestication--
10,000 years ago, the
Neolithic period, which I
mentioned before.
This being cellular
agriculture, a reflection
of not only our
ethical evolution,
but also our increased
understanding of science
and being able to cut
animals out of the equation
and get right to the
heart of the matter.
I believe so firmly
in the ability
for clean meat and plant-based
meat to revolutionize the way
that we eat, and in the
process, eliminate factory
farming that I helped start
The Good Food Institute,
which you heard a
little bit about before.
This is a nonprofit
that supports
the entire plant-based
and clean meat
sector by supporting scientists
and technology, innovation,
and policy work, making sure
that when clean meat comes
to market, that it won't face
any legal hurdles and community
engagement.
Also, starting new crop
capital-- putting our money
where our mouth is.
Doing angel seed investing
in companies that are high
risk, but have the potential
to change the world.
Investing in companies, like
Memphis Meats, Beyond Meat,
Lyrical Foods, Good Catch--
companies that are
seeking to create vegan,
plant-based
alternatives to fish.
We are racing towards having
a fishless ocean by 2048,
with most of the wild
stocks in severe decline.
This is a moral and
ethical issue as much
as it is a conservation and
environmental issue as well.
And we have good company
with these investments
that we are making-- perhaps
unusual, you might think.
The Tyson Foods CEO says
that the future of food
might be meatless, reflecting
a 5% investment that they
recently did in Beyond Meat.
Cargill, one of the largest
meat companies in the US,
recently did an investment
alongside Bill Gates and others
in Memphis Meats itself.
This is something
that I welcome.
Just as the car changed
the transportation sector,
we believe that
plant-based and clean meat
can change the protein sector.
So we want companies in the
protein sector to embrace this,
make this part of
their business plan.
And we are seeing that happen
at an alarmingly great rate.
Now, I want to talk a little
bit about change over time.
Just a few years ago,
people would say clean meat,
ending factory farming,
this is crazy talk,
it's never going to happen.
This is too deeply ingrained
in our culture and our beliefs,
but a little bit of
historical perspective I think
can show how quickly
things can change.
Dr. King once said that the
arc of the moral universe
is long, but bends
towards justice.
And this is true.
Our history books are filled
with examples of this.
But that arc of
the moral universe,
it doesn't bend on its own.
It doesn't bend because
of the weight of time.
It bends because thoughtful,
committed, concerned people
step up to the plate
and they take action,
whether that's protesting,
speaking out, founding
organizations, supporting
organizations, or being
innovators in the space.
Just 150 years ago, we ended
slavery in this country--
owning another human,
considering them
as chattel and property.
97 years ago, women were
finally given the right to vote.
There were impassioned
debates in Congress
about women being too
irrational of creatures
to be able to vote.
Funny considering
the situation today.
Just 53 years ago,
we ended segregation
in this country-- something
that was fought tooth and nail.
Just 50 years ago, in
Loving versus Virginia,
interracial marriage was
legalized across the United
States, striking
down certain state
laws that made it a crime.
People were arrested
in their own homes
because of who they loved.
And just two years ago,
my love, and others
in the LGBT community, finally
recognized in our country
on a national level with
the Supreme Court decision.
Now, when I grew up
on a farm in Ohio,
I was called a faggot before I
knew what the word even meant.
And I was taught
and told by society
that my love wasn't equal, and
I can tell you, at a young age,
there were many times when
I thought that I would never
be able to get married.
That society would never
progress to a point
where that would happen.
And I can only imagine,
when people like Rosa Parks
are being dragged off of
buses, that they probably
didn't know when
or if they would
see those changes
in their lifetime,
but they pushed forward.
And society is
better because of it.
Nelson Mandela who was a
political prisoner, released,
and became the president
of South Africa, once
said, "It always seems
impossible until it's done."
And then it seems inevitable.
And again, we can
look at history books,
and we can say, of
course, slavery would end.
Of course, women would be
given the right to vote.
Of course,
segregation would end.
But again, it didn't
happen on its own.
Now Peter Singer, author
of "Animal Liberation"
and many other wonderful books,
once said it's easy for us
to criticize the prejudices
of our grandfathers
from which they freed
themselves from their fathers,
but it is more difficult for
us to dispassionately search
for prejudices in
our own beliefs.
And I believe that
animal protection,
animal rights is a
social justice issue.
And if we look at the number of
individuals that are suffering
and the degree to which
they are suffering,
I think it is one of the most
pressing social justice issues.
And it is different from other
past movements in the sense
that those who are being
oppressed and marginalized,
they can't speak up
on their own behalf.
They can't stand up here
and share their stories.
They can't lobby
Congress to pass laws.
They can't organize boycotts.
They rely on each
and every one of us
to do that on their behalf in
our own unique and meaningful
ways.
But if we stop for a moment
and we look and we listen,
we see that these
animals are protesting.
They are struggling.
They are trying to save their
own lives and often times,
the lives of others
that they care about.
This is an image from China
of a brave pig who jumped out
of the top of a
moving transport truck
on her way to slaughter
to save her own life.
And it seems like every few
weeks, every few months,
we see stories in
the paper of animals
who jumped over fences to save
themselves from slaughter.
And when that happens, everyone
rallies behind those animals.
They want them to be saved.
They want them to
go to sanctuaries.
Each animal deserves that.
I just want to share this story,
which I'm sure many of you
have heard before.
A little boy is at the
beach with his grandfather,
and there are hundreds
of starfish that
have washed up along the shore.
And the little boy is tossing
them back into the water, one
after the next.
And his grandfather looks at him
and says, what are you doing?
There are maybe thousands
of starfish here.
You can't possibly
save them all.
And the little boy smiles
back at his grandfather.
He reaches down.
He picks up another starfish
and gently tosses him back
into the water.
And he said, it
matters to this one.
And he reaches back down,
picks up another one,
puts him back in
the water, and says,
and it matters to this one.
And to me, this story
really illustrates the power
that we have to save
lives, to prevent cruelty,
to improve the world.
And how any act of kindness is
never wasted in little choices
that we make.
Maybe it's the food
choices that we
make that can have profound
consequences for animals.
It can be the difference
between life or death.
So I leave you with this quote
from Harriet Beecher Stowe.
She said, it's a
matter of taking
the side of the weak
against the strong--
something the best
people have always done.
And it is difficult to
imagine a group of individuals
who are weaker and more
vulnerable than animals.
And within that
group, farmed animals.
So thank you for being
here and for being
on the side of the
weak and vulnerable.
[APPLAUSE]
Do we have time for questions?
AUDIENCE: So, we see things
like "Happy Feet," where
an animal's communicating
with the world, and we all
[INAUDIBLE],, but I feel
like they communicate
with us all of the time.
So what, for instance, from
connecting our emotions
that we have for our pets
with all of the other animals
that we see in the world?
I know some of it is
a bit brainwashing,
but what inherently
is preventing us
from making that connection?
I don't understand.
NATHAN RUNKLE: Yeah, I mean,
on this sort of brainwashing,
Melanie Joy has written a book--
well, she's written three books.
One is called "Why We Eat Pigs,
Wear Cows, and Love Dogs."
And she talks about
carnism, which
is this invisible belief that
allows us to eat some animals,
but not others.
And the truth is that we
don't eat most animal species.
It's actually a very small
number of cows, pigs, chickens,
turkeys, ducks.
And it really is a belief system
that allows us to do that.
I think that part of it is that
it is social conditioning that
is reinforced all
the time, and we
don't know that we're being
conditioned in that way.
It starts at a very
young age, especially
in the United States
and Western cultures.
So I think part of it is
that these animals are
sort of ghosts in our
industrial machine.
People don't see them.
You go to the grocery store and
you pick up a package of meat
and it doesn't resemble an
animal, and we call it beef
or we call it pork.
So I think that's
a big part of it,
is people are able to have
willful ignorance that they
don't want to know about
something so they're not
going to.
And I think that that is
one of the driving forces.
And there's also just
so many social norms.
People don't even
realize that they're
making a choice so much.
So I think that that's one
of the most important things,
is as plant-based eating,
as vegan eating becomes more
mainstream, and people
see others doing it
and it becomes a default
option, that will go a long way.
But part of what we want
to do with The Good Food
Institute, for example, is the
three main factors for people
in their eating is
convenience, taste, and price.
So we want to make the
compassionate choice
the default choice
so that maybe we
don't need to win over
everyone's hearts and minds,
but they can simply
go to a store
and that's what they're eating.
And maybe it's clean
meat and it's real meat,
it's just produced
in a different way.
So I think that that's
really exciting,
and I think, honestly,
the way that we're
going to drive down consumption
as quickly as we can.
Yeah, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Do you have a list,
or some sort of resource
where you have
meat producers that
do use humane processes today?
NATHAN RUNKLE: We don't.
So Mercy for Animals
is never going
to endorse a meat company.
Like I said, we think
the only compassionate
choice is a plant-based diet.
But as I said before,
we believe that it's
our obligation to prevent as
much suffering as possible.
So that means pushing companies
away from this process.
So we don't have a
list of companies
that we endorse,
and we never will.
But there are different
labeling programs that are used.
And people who aren't yet ready
to go completely plant based,
I think the best thing you
can do is eat less meat.
I think a lot of
people will think,
hey I don't identify as vegan,
I don't think I ever could.
That's OK.
If everyone ate
meatless on Monday,
a billion fewer animals
would be killed.
And if people start moving in
that direction, it's better.
So people, especially
as they are starting,
shouldn't view this
as an all or nothing.
Because when people do that,
oftentimes they do nothing.
And we need people to make
choices that help animals.
But the labels that are thrown
around can be so deceptive.
For example, there's the
American Humane Association,
which certifies Foster Farms
chicken and Butterball.
It's essentially a completely
meaningless program.
It really just rubber stamps
what the industry is already
doing.
And we've seen this
with the egg industry.
A few years ago, they started
Animal Care Certified labeling,
which meant they took one bird
out of each cage, that's it.
The Better Business
Bureau got involved,
they said this is misleading.
So they change it to United
Egg Producer certified.
So the industry knows that
people care about this.
There's a lot of humane
washing that's happening.
So if you are going to
choose to eat these products,
I think at the very
least, you should
know what the labels mean.
Because they can vary so much.
And you just need to do
your own research on that.
I know that there is Farm
Forward, an organization that
works on animal welfare
issues for food,
has a website called
buyingpoultry.com,
where they try to
aggregate that information
in one place for people.
AUDIENCE: Have you faced
any sort of resistance
from the meat industry?
Have there been any instances
of [INAUDIBLE] from them?
NATHAN RUNKLE: No, they love me.
[LAUGHTER]
We're best friends.
Yeah, I mean of course.
So I think a number of things.
One is they are trying
to make it a crime for us
to do investigations.
So around 2011, a new wave of
ag-gag bills were introduced.
Agriculture gag
bills, a term coined
by Mark Bittman, who was at "The
New York Times" at the time.
These bills come
in three flavors.
Some of them are outright
ban on video and photographs.
Others relate to
job applications.
Others relate to turning
all of your footage
over to law enforcement
and no one else.
But these have been heavily
pushed by the meat industry.
And the dairy industry has
been very much behind them.
So that's one of the big
pushbacks from the industry.
But each company is
different, I will say.
Every company is
run by individuals,
so they have their own culture.
And some companies,
including meat companies,
when we've done
investigations, have
responded by saying yes,
there is a problem here.
Let's talk about
what some solutions
are that we could implement,
that would make things better.
So that is one outcome.
Others, like Tyson,
and like Cargill,
like I said, while they're
still doing horrible things
for the animals they're
raising, are investing
in these alternatives.
Which is smart.
You look at the energy
sector, and the smart ones
are investing in green energy.
You can either choose to
fight and change progress,
or you can jump on board
and be a champion for it.
So I think we're seeing
more and more of that.
And I think that we'll
continue to see that trend.
Again, these are companies
that really view themselves
as protein companies.
They're not in the business
of just torturing animals.
That's the old way
of doing things,
and they're doing
it as efficiently
as they feel that they can.
But I think that there really
won't be much of a choice
but to move in this direction.
The planet won't be able
to survive without it.
AUDIENCE: So I have a
question from Menohar,
what is being done to make
sure that Tyson, et cetera,
will not gain enough shares
of these meatless ventures
to prevent them from succeeding?
Or to own the patents and
intellectual property,
et cetera, or to negatively
control the activities
of these ventures.
NATHAN RUNKLE: Yeah,
that's a good question.
So I'm not too
concerned about them
trying to put these
places out of business.
Again, I think the business
case for this is very strong.
It can be far more efficient.
So again, they're in
the protein space.
They're not committed
to just continuing
to slaughter animals.
And if you look through
the history of, let's say,
plant-based meat
alternatives, Gardein
was recently purchased for
$150 million by Pinnacle Foods.
That's actually increased
their distribution.
That's actually gotten them into
more places, larger advertising
budgets.
We've seen this with lot of--
Silk and other
dairy alternatives.
They're being purchased
by dairy companies.
And they're not trying to
shelve those, or push them away,
they're actually
increasing their sales.
These are for-profit businesses.
They want to make money
where it can happen.
So I'm not too
concerned about that.
But the owners of those
companies, I'm sure,
are keeping an eye on it.
If you look at the innovators
in this space, many of them
are mission driven.
They want to help animals
and the environment, as well.
AUDIENCE: How are you
working in the health area
with information
that can help people
stop eating meat without fear
of malnutrition, et cetera.
NATHAN RUNKLE: Yes, and
this is a great question.
We do touch some, on health.
There's two approaches.
We need to talk about the
why people should change
their diet, but we also
need to equally talk
about how people should
change their diet.
Because if not, you
get a lot of people
who agree in theory, that
plant-based eating is good,
but they don't
know how to do it.
So a lot of our
education work is
done in providing people with
just the simple meal plans,
and how to be healthy,
and all of that.
So that's a big part
of those programs.
We are an animal protection
organization, however,
so we're not a health
care organization.
So that's not our primary focus.
That's not really where our
expertise and credibility
comes in.
But there are organizations
that are doing that,
like Physicians Committee
for Responsible Medicine.
There are incredible
resources and books,
Dr. Gregor, "How Not to
Die," things like that.
So we do direct people
in those ways as well.
We want people on a
vegan diet to be healthy.
Because you're going to be more
likely to stay with the diet.
Recidivism is so
high with veganism.
A lot of that is just
a social element.
People don't realize the
social impact that going vegan
can have.
And so they want to get
back into the social graces
of people.
So that is part of what we do.
People can go to
chooseveg.com, we
have a lot of health
information there.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have any pointers
on how to talk to
kids, and specifically
other people's children?
Because kids usually
have questions,
like, why don't you eat that.
And the honest
answer of I don't eat
cows is a very enlightening
experience for children.
NATHAN RUNKLE: I
don't have any kids.
I do have three nieces who are
all self-declared vegetarian
or vegan, including my niece
Bella, who puts her allowance
money towards a pig at Animal
Place that she's adopted.
So she goes and sees this pig.
Look, I think kids are much
brighter than a lot of people
give them credit for.
And I think that they can
understand these concepts
much better than people
give them credit for.
And I think that the
default for kids and humans
is to be compassionate and
have empathy for animals.
I don't think that I was
unique in my interest
in animals growing up on a farm.
In fact, I saw that with all
of my friends who were in 4H.
And they would raise pigs
and cows for slaughter.
And they would give
these animals names,
and they would bottle
feed them, and they
would stay up at night with
them if they were sick.
And then they would sell them
by the pound to go to slaughter.
And every single
one of those kids,
essentially, was
heartbroken, and would cry,
and would want to save
that animal that year.
But then as the
years go on, they're
just told that's the way it is.
That's what these animals are
here for, we have to do this.
And you could sort
of slowly see kids
becoming desensitized and
changing their view on it.
So I don't have, really,
specific advice on this,
but I think it needs to be
appropriate given the age.
I think really young
kids, we probably
can talk to them in a
way that doesn't involve
gory slaughterhouse footage.
And that would probably
go over better.
But I think that we can
talk to kids about animals
having personalities.
And if they have a dog or
a cat, that pigs and cows
are exactly the same.
I think they can
understand that concept
I think it becomes challenging
when parents aren't
supportive of that, because
then you have kids that get it,
but they can't get food if
their parents aren't supportive.
And that way, I think
it's important to have
meaningful conversations
with parents as well.
And encourage them to support
the children's curiosity
about this.
But that's easier said than
done, perhaps, sometimes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This question isn't
really for me.
I've been vegetarian,
or vegan, for 30 years.
NATHAN RUNKLE: Wow.
AUDIENCE: I think it's just,
it's been awesome for me.
I have great energy.
It's been amazing.
Clean meat, I
would never eat it.
I would never try it.
I don't miss meat.
I don't want to ever have meat.
But what are the ethical
dimensions, maybe
for some people who are
vegetarian or vegan?
NATHAN RUNKLE: Yeah.
Well, personally, I don't
care if vegetarians or vegans
eat clean meat.
It's really not for
vegetarians or vegans.
So if you're a happy
vegetarian or vegan,
and you want to eat beans,
nuts, legumes, awesome.
Continue to do it.
I think clean meat is really
about the 98% of Americans,
and people around the globe,
that aren't vegetarian.
That don't want to
become vegetarian.
That want to
continue to eat meat.
So that's kind of my take on it.
I'm not here to try to
convince vegans to eat it.
I want meat eaters to eat it.
Yeah.
Thank you everyone,
so much for spending
your afternoon with me.
[APPLAUSE]